dutch voters had to wait nine months to
see the same faces from the same parties
announcing a new government acting prime
minister margaret of the center-right
favorite a party promised a new start
with the democrats christian democrats
and a small christian party
the exact same coalition was forced to
step down earlier this year after almost
50 000 parents were wrongly accused by
tax authorities of child care benefit
fraud an investigation found that some
were victims of racial profiling
natasha deepai was forced to pay back
nearly 120 thousand dollars and lost her
job her house and suffered from strokes
like
i think it's inhumane i don't understand
how this is possible they have done this
to us and not only to us but to so many
people how is it possible that the same
people who did this can still be there
so it's not
in their coalition agreement the parties
acknowledge the first thing they need to
do is to restore trust a recent survey
showed that only 16 percent of dutch
people still have confidence in the
government strategy to tackle the covet
pandemic riots broke out in several
cities in response to restrictions why
didn't you decide if we want a new
government with a new face
this is not my i should not run i should
not of course i'm always responsible for
everything which is not going well
that's absolutely correct so the child
benefits scandal of course it happened
on my watch it was not my personal doing
but absolutely true i was prime minister
when it happened so many of you don't
understand you're you're here again
you're the new prime minister yes but we
stepped down as a government in january
we fought the elections in march and my
party won
after nine months and at times painful
negotiations the new government looks
very much like the old one and although
the 50-page agreement promises ambitious
plans and a new approach many wonder if
it will be enough to restore confidence
in politics
the new government has allocated
billions for far-reaching climate
policies to build new houses and improve
the education system i would say we have
a leadership problem in the netherlands
for instance our prime minister
positions himself explicitly as a
political manager and he declines to
show any moral leadership on important
issues
say what the rule of law is what the
significance of loneliness is in the
kovitz pandemic
so it's only managing
pressing problems but no vision but
will most likely lead his fourth cabinet
is optimistic the new government that
took so long to build will bring change
although some worry it might not live
long enough to fulfill its promises step
faster al jazeera the hague